let's touch on the city okay when I
moved to New York it was the craziest
time of my life everything was new my
friends my job and my boyfriend but
things changed quickly in the city and
now nothing was the same were there a
lot of moments where you just were like
I wish my life was not on TV it's all
the time yeah especially because I ended
up marrying one of the producers all
right so while I was on the city and
like I really liked him it just made me
so much more insecure about everything
because I was like oh my god one of the
producers I'm like super into and also
when they were set me up on dates in New
York City and I really did like this
producer and I was like I don't want to
do this like I wanna do this in front of
him and he actually was in charge of
like finding guys to go out on dates
with me and he didn't want to that hi
there like he was always trying to pawn
that job on someone else you should have
just sabotage all of them just I think
he did because they were all terrible
dates and I never ended up liking any of
them so it's possible blind dates they
can even be like pretty fun
were the most horrible thing ever basic
yeah I was able to pursue my my now has
been once the city was over and I moved
back to Los Angeles half it's like okay
now like finally single I'm living in LA
we're not filming the show like I can I
consistently how long after the city
under did you move back to LA like
literally immediately say life is would
make you baby if you could go back and
do it all again would you for sure
definitely looking back on and maybe not
in the moment but looking back on it it
was a really really cool opportunity and
a very unique one and I would have never
met my husband right it's like the most
amazing thing so oh yeah I would do it
all over again for sure
you